this entrenches Vodafone's market
leadership of the cable industry in
germany is it going to pass muster with
regulators it's going to be a challenge
because the regulators have previously
been skeptical but I would say since the
last time this was tried a few years ago
the regulatory model has evolved and of
course the distribution of things like
television and broadband have evolved as
well there are more technologies doing
various so it is not it good to be a
challenge but it's not impossible yeah I
mean the chief executive of Deutsche
Telekom to which they're now the second
biggest player in fixed line telecom
says it's an unacceptable deal and he's
going to fly too you've got to remember
that most of Vodafone competitors will
use this as an opportunity to pitch
their own arguments to see what they can
get out of this deal as a consequence as
a remedy from the regulators so they're
all in pitching mode as well in general
I think Georgia telecom would probably
recognize that there is room for
consolidation but the challenges in
Germany with the way housing
associations are built and the
monopolistic providing that cable has of
those it's a little bit more of a
structural challenge than you get in
other markets so what do you think of
the price at those phones paying here
price was a full price but not a huge
surprise I mean we've been talking about
a number of around 18 to 19 billion
euros and it came in that range I mean
what this doesn't provide Vodafone with
of course is a UK cable TV business I
mean there's been a lot of speculation
that virgin media it was in talks to buy
that which is also called sewn by
Liberty global why don't you think
that's been included I hear there's a
couple reasons firstly Vodafone is more
of a consumer operator in its
continental European property so
therefore cable fits so I'm saying it
doesn't fit in the UK but it's not as
much of a priority a lot of vodafone in
the UK is actually a business mobile
operator the other side of it is just
sheer scale you know a virgin in the UK
is far bigger and doing both at the same
time would be a hard thing to stomach
financially and would increase the risk
profile it's not to say it won't be
there in the longer term but it's
probably not going to be something that
they can afford in the immediacy
so what does Liberty global do now I
mean it gets nearly 11 billion euros
worth of cash out of this what's he
gonna do with the money it has options
doesn't it I mean if
wants to pursue a standalone strategy in
the UK then it might look at mobile
assets if you think about other parts of
the Liberty global group in Europe for
example in the Netherlands and in
Belgium they have acquired mobile assets
themselves so they could be a go alone
strategy or they might just wait and
return the money to shareholders in the
short term to see if there's further
consolidation of the UK further down the
line or they could even I guess bulk up
Virgin Media by buying another mobile
operator like Oh - yeah I mean that is a
possibility
Oh - we've known historically has been
looked to be a fair trade sale
Telefonica its owner has talked about an
IPO of that asset so there is
potentially a willing seller there so if
the price is right and what about ITV I
mean Liberty global owns nearly 10% of
that the old investment bankers have had
the bellows out trying to reignite that
story today haven't they yeah I think
however the thing the telecoms
infrastructure is probably slightly more
important as you look forward in the
longer term into the developments of 5g
what does that mean for cable the
combination of fixed and mobile assets
together I think that's probably more of
a priority rather than necessarily
adding an advertising based content
provider yeah I mean Virgin Media I
think they said in May last year they
weren't interested in ITV at its current
share price the share price has fallen
by quarter since then you could argue
that that was a good call on their case
but yeah I mean in theory it is cheaper
to buy now but the other side of it is
you've got to think what is it actually
brewing virgin has a lot of
subscription-based model and ITV isn't a
subscription-based model it's a free to
advertising based model so it is a
different type of business model not
saying never but it is a different time
and very briefly guide you see other
convergence deals happening in the TMT
sector this way they're happening around
to be honest with you I mean this is
probably a big one but they've been
going on in places like the Netherlands
places like Austria are already so this
is a pan-european theme this is just
another big one to add to that list